good morning everyone thanks for being
here at 9:00 after the party I know it
must be tough my name is Selena I'm
assistant professor at Delft University
of Technology I'm on Twitter as well so
if you're tweeting about this look you
can mention me so I can see all the nice
things that people think about this book
we're going to talk about programming
and writing today but this first who
knows who said this everyone should
learn programming yes every programmer
ever
don't you agree I mean we all love
programming so I'm sure all of you at
one point have said everyone should
learn programming get you in programming
because it's really important but of
course leads to the question what is
programming it's huge thing and if you
say everyone should learn programming
what exactly is it that you mean with
the words programming and this reminds
me of one of my favorite jokes where you
have this old fish he's swimming and he
meets two little young fish and he says
hey folks how's the water and the little
fishies say what's water they don't know
what order is there in water the only
thing they know is water a fish has
never been in air so he doesn't really
conceive water as a thing it's just
everything that's there and I think for
some people in programming it's also
like this the only thing we see is
programming so what it actually means to
people that are no programming either in
the air is very very hard for us to get
a hold of let's go back a little bit
because I'm going to share some personal
stories here let's go back to the year
2008 this is when I started grad school
and I moved from Ankara in the tiny tiny
country of Netherlands to Delft which is
about 100 kilometers and distance for
luenell super impressive the urban for
us it's really on the other side of the
country and I went to work at tu Delft
University I'm still working at and my
research assignment there was to build a
DSL a domain-specific language for
finance so a programming language
specifically designed for financial
institutions and
you my supervisor we envision something
like this a programming language in
which financial experts could express
their domain in a way that's readable to
them something like if we if the
interest is too high we have to sell
this or something like that so I started
an internship at an insurance company so
again I was just starting grad school
are still young I didn't really know a
lot about the world and what they told
me University was more or less this
there exists users and there exist
programmers and I don't need you all in
between ever a little hole to it today
sometimes communicated a little bit
their users and the programmers and
users used in a programmers program this
more or less the few I got when I was in
university however reality when I
started this internship in the insurance
company was somewhat different I found
out that all the people program also
users normal people meet initiated human
beings can do some programming the
people that were experts insurance
experts accountants people like that
they were absolutely programming however
they didn't use a programming language
as most people define programming
languages because they were using
spreadsheets
this was their programming language so I
went back to the university went back to
my supervisor I said and they don't need
a DSL in finance they have a DSL in
finance and it's cool Excel this is a
programming language that works for
financial experts if the language they
understands spreadsheets are code and
this became the motto of my PhD
dissertation spreadsheets are code
spreadsheets are away a means of
expression in the program for people
that aren't necessarily self-identifying
as programmers and not only our
spreadsheets codes they are functional
code because think about it if for Allah
in a spreadsheet the only thing it can
do is reference other cells and
calculate a new value based on the
references so spreadsheets by definition
are side-effects free because the only
thing they can do is change their own
little cell even more so if we're
talking about both words spreadsheets
are also reactive programming because
the cell is updated when the cells in
the pen zone are updated and it's not
the gate that the entire spreadsheet is
recalculated so it's a reactive
functional programming system that's
used by 750 million people isn't that
remarkable
so the spreadsheets are code as I said
with a muscle of my PhD dissertation
it's research that I've done for a
number of years around the idea that
spreadsheets don't really have an IDE if
you look at eclipse or Visual Studio
those are systems made to support you in
programming they help you understand
source code there are lots of features
in an IDE that help you understand
source code for example visualization
but also smell detection and refactoring
support all sorts of features that make
you write better source code and if you
look at a spreadsheet and often is not
just one worksheet but a collection of
worksheets that are all connected with
each other how do you understand that
how do you measure the quality of that
and one of the core ideas that I
explored is code smells code smells as
originally defined for object-oriented
languages for example a very long
methods is a Goats map it might be
functioning perfectly fine however
because it's very long we know it's hard
for people to understand and another
code smell is a method with lots and
lots of parameters I'd be perfect
however if it's so many parameters it's
very hard to understand and those code
smells really nicely relate for example
on maps totals of duplication code
clones they really nicely relate to
spreadsheets because the long methods if
that's smelly
then a long formula is also going to be
smelling and if you have lots of clones
in your source code and that's bad then
if you have lots of duplication in the
formalize of your spreadsheet that's
going to lead to similar maintenance
issues so I wrote a number of papers
about detecting code smells in scratchy
formulas refactoring
spreadsheet formulas to increase quality
of spreadsheets and also detecting
clones into duplication in formats and
this eventually made me a real PhD now a
proper academic I graduated on the topic
of spreadsheet analysis and this story
is sort of the happy story that I've
told many times at conferences right
she's our code and it's also in our
smells and refactoring in tada
everyone's happy so it's sort of the
story of my brain it is what really
happens it's not fake news it actually
happened like this however it's only
maybe upper layer of the story because
there's also the story of the heart and
during this period
thanks for happening to me that warrant
super happy so look at me if this is mm
send I'm very happy I'm eager like I'm
this morning like Oh your spreadsheets
are code everything is awesome I'm going
to conferences like this and telling
people in spreadsheets are code and then
people said this all the time
spreadsheets aren't real real
programming it is it's programming but
it is not real programming it is too
easy and I'm like yes but they're there
from slow programming and you're
wrapping the whole runs I just did like
Oh awesome yeah it's still not real
programming because it doesn't it
doesn't fit our world it cannot be
programming because everyone can do it
so it can you know be programming this
is it doesn't fit our view and this
continues for a while for for a few
years and people keep saying kept saying
spreadsheets is not is not real and
after a while it really wears you out I
mean it's sort of it's fun to be the
underdog and to change people's mind for
a while but after ten years you're still
trying to explain people that what
you're doing is actually really
important to many people and people keep
laughing in your face if you say my PC
dissipation is about spreadsheets
it doesn't do nothing with you it so
after a while I didn't really really
realize I wasn't into it anymore but it
sort of happened that I went out to do
other things and and this is my
reflection now that contributed to that
so what happened Agusta
I was sort of heartbroken and I don't
really know what to do and then through
networking I run into a community center
in my neighborhood that needed a
programming teacher he said every
Saturday can you come in to teach us
kids some programming oh yeah I can do
that I know programming so I'm sure I
can teach you to add roles value totally
finding they'll have zero experience
this is what having a p2b Dustin is you
think I am smart and one thing so I am
smart in all the things I give you that
this this will be easy so in the
community center they had a lego robot a
Lego Mindstorms robot who has programmed
Lego Mindstorms cool like to test it for
your kids right know for your personal
enjoyment medals so they had this like a
robot and it's a system that you program
in a visual way it looks more or less
like this so you have little blocks and
you connect them with wires to to rotate
the servos or to read a sensor and to
act based upon that and of course when
it kids went home I was no playing with
her robots I was looking at their
programs and as I mean I've seen this
before because those programs little bit
ladies pictures they weren't really
necessarily very well structured there
was some duplication in these programs
there were some unnecessary connections
I'm like hmm
this looks like goat smells in Lego
Mindstorms this is exactly the same type
of patterns I saw in the spread in the
spreadsheet
I also saw in the children because like
spreadsheet users all novice programmers
including kids they're very goal-driven
they just want the machine to work they
want to Roble to run and if they've
achieved that goal they're done and then
they move on to their next assignment
like an accountant is making a budget
and if it works they're happy their goal
is in programming their goal is their
own job or their own hobby so we saw
very similar code smells and I was
talking with a colleague in the US that
had also done some research into the
programming language code ooh it's a
Microsoft programming language also
aimed at children and we saw similar
patterns there as well so it sounds good
I'll just write one little program about
Lego Mindstorms code smells I was not at
all at that point aiming for a change of
direction I just love them I saw the
interesting thing on the Saturday so
that let's just write it down because
I'm a scientist and I can do that but of
course you know you know if ten minutes
in this talk this is not going to be the
only favor about this topic because then
I started wondering of course is it that
bad our code smells bad does it matter
to novice programmers if their programs
are really smelly because contrary to
traditional software and contrary also
to spreadsheets maybe those programs
don't really stay alive for a very long
time or if they're bad and maybe it
doesn't matter if they're small maybe it
doesn't even hamper understand ability
of kids so this is when we moved on to a
programming language called scratch who
you scratch it's so cool it's a visual
programming language is made by MIT it's
free and open-source you will see some
examples of how it looks like later and
it allows kids through program games and
animations in the browser it's really
easy you don't have to install anything
it just runs in the browser we did an
experiment with these are fresh gates I
wasn't working in the community center
anymore because you can only
experimental children for so long so we
had 61 high school kids in the
Netherlands that we randomly divided
into three different groups one group
got nice perfectly designed scratch code
and one group got code that had lots of
duplication repetition similar blocks in
different places and one group got long
methods so all the blocks together in
one script and we gave them a game like
a breakout like game in scratch and we
asked them to explain the game what is
happening in it and also to adapt the
game to make little changes to it and
then we can measure whether the nice
group did it better or differently than
the too smelly groups so question are
smells bad short answer is yes code
smells are bad also for kids also for
novice programmers are just learning it
if you make a program that has
duplication it will harm their
understanding the nice group the nice
group did better on the assignment of
explaining and adapting the source code
so maybe two papers maybe one little
favor
one more those smells are bad also for
programmers but then of course you start
wondering if people ask you like oh yeah
your research and goat smells and
scratch but does it actually happen is
this purely your new academic homie or
is this a thing that occurs then we
wanted to know our code smells Coleman
in scratch is this something that
happens in the field in wild or it is
just something that we invented and put
it in this program so what we did is we
downloaded 250,000 programs we can
scratch it's not only open-source it
also has a repository in which children
can share their programs and all the
programs that are shared are Creative
Commons so you can do everything with
them you can play them you can change
the programs if you want to you can
print the source code out or have it
tattooed on your back or you can do some
static source code analysis on it which
of course is the most desirable of those
options we downloaded 250,000 programs
and we found that 30% of the program's
suffers from long method smell so that's
quite some programs that are non
well-structured and we knew from the
previous study that this will hamper
understandability and as I said there's
a public repository so these programs do
get shared programs that are on the
homepage sometimes get thousands of
views and thousands of remixes so gets
baked like Forks you take them and make
them their own so they are exposed
likely to bad source code with wrong
method and 26% of the programs had
duplication so this is something that's
bad and we also know it's common
something else that we found in this
study we weren't really looking for
every we were looking for code smells
but a very surprising finding that I'll
talk about more in the remaining of my
talk is that about half of the programs
only had interaction so half of the
programs did something like if you press
a button if you click the mouse if you
make a sounds
the other half had no interaction
whatsoever and this this is water of
programming like stuff because I was
thinking scratch is from games where
kids are making our game so there must
be interaction so this finding was like
this this is weird I don't really know
how it fits in my mental model of what
programming is but we will come back to
that finding later of course there was
another favor
we then figured out how to code and how
we can analyze the source code I then
wanted to know can we teach code smells
because we know it's bad we know it's
common what can we do against it can we
educate kids to understand code smells
can we educate kids to not make code
smells even so we then is we created an
online course on EDX org where we
explain children scratch and about 3000
kids participated in our first
experiment so that was that was
wonderful and we we did some moderate
lining Swedish children because we told
them it was a programming course or just
that this course will feature scratch
nothing else
however really we have programming
in the course but also code smells so
every week I explain the programming
concepts like a loop or condition but
also I said here's an example you know
this is very long maybe you could also
split it and then it would be more
readable and even sets of children that
we did experiments in university and
where we measured that those small
scripts are easier to understand and
with that we could measure if it's
possible to teach mouths because of
course not only had videos but also
quizzes so we could measure do the kids
score better on the programming concepts
and on the smells concepts or do they
really understand the smells can we
explain code smells and the short answer
is yes gives it significantly better on
the smells questions 85 points on
average out of 100 for the programming
concept 72 points out of 100 so it's
even the case that the questions about
code smells were so more
easier to understand than questions
about smells and these were seven to
eleven year olds to really young kids
already can reason about the quality of
source code is what we found here so
that's that's a promising story I guess
my not so very secret multi year of
course is that these children those ten
year olds in eight years they'll be in
my university classroom so if I get them
one by young and I teach them about code
smells then maybe in a decade my life
will be easier because if I don't teach
them then those eight year olds will say
hey you know I tell them don't do code
smells because it's bad and they're like
yeah but we're doing this for a year see
sure why change now so this is my secret
motivation that I want to teach about
code smells while also learning program
so at this point we're about in year now
in this story of programming for kids I
am figuring out that this is maybe my
new topic because I've now done four
papers about different aspects of code
smells and programming for kids so it's
not just this one-off thing anymore and
at that point I think maybe it's time to
move back maybe it's time to look at the
water of programming I was in because
because it was such an adventure that
just happened I didn't really have a
strategy sometimes if you make a plan
like I had in my previous rotation you
have a clear plan and you think about
what is my vision and what is my
research philosophy before you start but
it sort of just happened so after a
while I wanted to go back and understand
what what is it I'm doing and I realized
that I was making many many assumptions
so for example one of the assumptions
and maybe they occurred to you while I
was speaking one of the assumptions that
I made is the domain is irrelevant in
the first study we did with the code
smells I didn't even think whether or
not I would do a game and whether or not
that would be the best representation it
was a non decision I just thought Oh
scratch games fun I didn't consider the
impact of that only experiments where it
should usually if you're a researcher
you think about what are the impacts of
all the choices you may
around your research design for example
where I said you know you need fresh
children it's sort of a joke but it's
also decays that if children know you
very well that might change the results
of your experiment and of course also
the type of program you choose will
influence the results of your experiment
potentially but I didn't even think
about it was just programming games gets
done that was the first one the other
one and I talked about that already a
little bit is I assumed software does
something and this is why the result
that only half of the scratch programs
have user interaction surprised me I
didn't really know how to fit that into
my mental model of programming and the
third assumption I made is building is
learning so when we started the online
course I didn't think of other ways of
teaching programming I could have taught
programming by having kids reprograms or
speak them aloud or deconstruct them but
immediately I thought if you just build
source code kids will learn how to build
source code and while this seems very
logical if you think of many other areas
where you're training something you
often train weird things that you're
never going to do for example if you
train for a marathon
and we're going to do a marathon three
times a week what you do is one slow
long-distance training and maybe one
interval training and maybe even some
weight lifting or biking or swimming
which is sort of weird because you're
never going to do those things in the
marathon however this is exactly the way
we train programming the only thing we
do is we train programming is doing the
exact thing that we're going to do later
in life so this is a deep assumption
that also I didn't really know how to
break but at least I said to myself
let's try to break those assumptions
let's take them pick them apart and see
what happens if I let those assumptions
go for example let's say the domain is
relevant so I asked many kids what do
you want to program instead of saying
I like games you like games left Oh mad
games I said well what do you want to do
what do you absolutely love and they
come up with the craziest things so one
of the kids and my Saturday's up it's
the weirdest things he says I wanted to
make a website for the local supermarket
this is what I want to do so he went
there and made photos with his mobile
phone put them on the website
she's nice because then people can know
when the supermarket is open so he put
the opening times there and the
telephone number and then even the
cutest he googles for the street name of
the supermarket and iGoogle doesn't show
his website is really disappointing to
be like why don't they show my website
it's so much prettier than the real one
so I got to also teach him something
about Google and the internet and this
is the weirdest thing what teacher ever
can come up with a programming exercise
that talks about the local supermarket
but this is something he was really
enthusiastic about so the atmosphere of
the classroom changed so much when I put
the domain first and when I worked with
the assumption that what they were
building absolutely worked for them so
one of the things that we also did it's
Donald Duck
you have the Donald Duck magazine in
here in North Norway is that a thing on
it's so cool because I gave this talk to
people in like Americans and they didn't
really understand how Donald Duck is a
thing still but in the Netherlands and
apparently also in Norway you have this
Donald Duck magazine that's still every
week or every month and and people read
it in the Netherlands we have 17 million
people and 1 million have a subscription
to dissolve that magazine everyone reads
that and the nice thing is that in
Istanbul you in a different universe
there are lots of different types of
stories you have low stories about
Donald Duck and they see the but you
also have these adventure stories which
scrooge mcduck wants to find a treasure
so it's a very rich universe that
everyone knows and this is what I
brought into my classroom so you can see
here this our classroom and you're all
these Donald Duck magazines that I
brought and I said to the kids take your
favorite story and recreate the Donald
Duck story in scratch you can pick
favorite to do it and I have an example
here the story
sadly I'm sorry this story isn't Dutch
however I think probably if you're a
Norwegian you can maybe you can read it
but the story is quite simple
one of the comes into the office and
then scrooge mcduck says sold what do
you have there it looks like a wants and
then it's not Donald Duck because it's
the witch lady that was pretending to be
Donald Duck and then
Scrooge McDuck says Oh for thematic ah
this is this rich lady oh no and then
she says I'm going to change you into a
frog and then from now on you'll be
known as the hobart frog and then he
changes into a frog which is it's a
simple story nothing really happens but
it's it's very very viable to program in
scratch because people that have done
scratch know that the sprites can change
into other sprites so let me show you
how this story can look like in scratch
what are you what do you have there is
like it was yes indeed I have something
for you
you'll be a frog and then it changes
into your frog so it's very very simple
to program in scratch because you can
have those sprites change appearance and
you clearly feel see the relationship
between what's happening in scratch and
the story even though of course it
doesn't really look that nice and a cool
thing here is that kids explore this
type of exercises in an entirely
different way so some kids were really
excited about making it look more like
the comic book so they started drawing
with scratch also allows it has like a
Fain's interface where you can change
the backgrounds other kids really
started to explore the rest of the story
because he's a frog now now what will
happen will he remain a frog will he
faith in his money bin as a frog so
there were different angles that kids
could take from this story and it was
really interesting to see the different
things that they did that the second
assumption of course that I had was that
all programs have interaction what
happens if you let that go what happens
if we start creating programs that don't
have interaction for example create
artworks so ask its again what do you
want to build what is what about arts
and then some kids say Pokemon this and
art firmness this isn't maybe that's
true but one of the things that we
explored is Mondrian Mondrian is a Dutch
painter maybe you heard of image was in
the style and he makes the same things
that are really abstract with lines and
squares and this is something that
really really is valuable as a metaphor
for programming so we I did that in a
big classroom art the university has get
seventy kids in a programming
competition and they wants me to
entertain them for an hour what we did
here is all the kids throw their own
mumbly and painting so here you see one
that's maybe will remind you most of
what they look like and these were those
very entrance from the kids they think
they will get a lecture about
programming they come into the classroom
and I had them a sheet of paper and
pencils and pens and I say you have to
make mommy I'm painting and these are
ten eleven year old kids and that's
already a boy that says this isn't
programming I will decide that sir
please don't make a painting he forsook
change okay
these happen that we are doing this we
are telling kids what is programming and
what is in programming but the cool
thing is so I have them draw these
paintings and then the next exercise
they have to compare their painting to
their neighbors painting and then they
can reason about abstraction because you
have blue and I have yellow that means
if we're going to create color in the
painting at least Koehler needs to be a
variable because we have different
colors and if one has lines like this
and the other one has lines like this
then the direction of the lines is going
to be a parameter into the program as
well so comparing these paintings is a
really nice way to talk about
abstraction before you talk about
abstraction in source code and later we
will see that in a scratch program we
created our own blocks with parameters
and then I had two pieces of source code
next to each other that will later
become the function
get this two pieces of programming what
is the difference because the difference
will become a parameter of the program
and then I'll of course I like I play
with them a little bit to see how how
important it was that you practiced
comparing things because you would need
that skill and programming they're like
oh oh maybe she knows what she's doing
so here's a program and you see here the
purple blobs are blobs that we created
ourselves so they're functions that you
can use in the program to generate many
different mobile um paintings and then
this is how it looks like so it creates
a line and then it creates another line
and then it creates a blue block of a
certain size and then with this program
all the kids were encouraged to recreate
their own paintings and then some
weren't possible because some didn't
have the proper construction yet one of
the bads made the victory boogie will be
one of the few paintings by Mondrian
that doesn't use this lines but they use
diagonal so yeah that is impossible it's
interesting to see what the boundaries
are as well so again it's a very very
interesting way of teaching programming
that's different from what we usually do
and then there was the third assumption
I still had left that was very as I said
before very deep building is learning if
we want to teach kids programming we
just have to do programming with them
it's really how most people teach
programming it's even in the leaf in the
university classroom teaching but also
teaching as in here at this conference
most of the people that do workshops or
to do talks through programming and they
show this is how you use our library
practicing what people would do if they
use the library rather I may be doing
weird exercises like the mobile yawns
that would benefit skills so what is the
reverse of billing is learning I wish I
had this story where I was sitting under
an apple tree in Cambridge and then but
ah Eureka but that is not really how it
happened it was more a process where I
was in Cambridge so that was a good
start I did a sabbatical there over
summer last year while I was thinking
about this but it was really a slow
process where I would
thinking about this every day and what
can we do the domain is relevant and
also no interaction is needed what does
this remind me of it's like writing
because if you think of writing the
domain of writing is really very
relevant we have all these different
professions all these people are
arguably writers they're writing as
their profession but it really matters
if you're a journalist or a poet what
you do with writing really influences
what your job is and how you look at
yourself and probably also how you look
at all the other professions so
embracing immediately you feel that if
you're a writer then what you do with
your writing will influence you in here
journalist is a container but that you
have financial journalists and political
journalists and economic journalists and
they all need not only writing skills
but also skills about the domain so in
writing the domain is absolutely number
one almost and of course I'm right and
you also don't really need interaction
because you I can write a book now and
you can read it in maybe 3,000 years so
in a book by definition there's no
interaction you just write it and it is
what it is and the interpretation has to
come from me
so programming is like writing is sort
of the conclusion that I that I arrive
that because if you think about it
ultimately what programming is is it
takes an idea a very very high-level
idea like an app that tracks complements
this is something what I want if someone
says something nice if you say can you
say that again record enough play
evacuator it's like Twitter but only the
good part you take that idea and what
you do is you transform that idea into
letters and sentences that's ultimately
what programming is an idea a very
high-level idea and it turns into
letters and sentences and maybe you use
some things in the meantime like a UML
diagram or a user story there are steps
in between but the idea is from idea to
letters
and this is what writing is - you have
an idea about a crazy story that you
might want to write like a frog murders
foreign diplomats because why not you
take that idea and you transform it into
letters and sentences that's ultimately
what writing is and like reprogramming
some people use things in the middle
some people use for example they write a
table of contents before that you can
start writing the story or their right
character sheets where they say this is
what the character is going to do even
though it doesn't appear in the story
just for them to get a feel for what's
in there so ultimately it's very very
very much the same and it's not just
that this is like hand waving if you
look at what people have written about
what programming is and what writing is
you see concepts that are really
familiar so for example here you see the
definition of what programming is by
provides a book from the 80s about how
to teach programming these are the steps
that people take when they're
programming so defining the program the
problem designing the solution writing
the source code compiling it running it
testing it and maintaining it those are
the traditional steps even though it
might be more cyclic in reality these
are the steps that people usually take
of their programming and then if you
look at rising writing traditionally
seen as gathering information selecting
the information structuring it
translating your ideas into letters or
words and sentences and then styling
formatting and reflecting on your tasks
and like with programming here is
usually a cycle where you're secretly
also reflecting while you're writing but
these are the steps and if they're in a
line it's nicely to put them next to
each other so here again you have the
steps of programming and writing next to
each other and you see that there are a
few cases that are really really very
similar gathering information and
defining your problem it is the same
thing those are understanding the
context of your problem the story or the
app and there are some that are somewhat
related so
in writing you have selecting
information and structuring information
which in programming is one thing
designing and on the other hand our
reflecting on source code is a bit more
structured we have testing and
maintaining that's of course because so
far is more a living system but still
this it's clear to see that there are
relationships between the different
steps I was also very interesting is
that writing is different also in some
cases because writing has three steps
for the real writing translating your
ideas stylizing and formatting
whereas in writing within source code
there's just a step writing the source
code and this comparison leads to
interesting definitions because widest
writing has stylizing well if you have
styling writing for example here is an
example of this is a hesitant style if
you read this piece of writing you're
like this person doesn't know what's
going on Iran are saying that it was the
same character in it but we're in front
of a church and from the Fraternal house
in front of the dustbin it expresses
hesitancy and confusion in the way it
uses words the information is still you
could also have said I don't know where
I met this person before but you use
style to emphasize confusion
what is this a programming do we have
different styles of expressing lines of
codes to express the feeling that we
have within so of course you can think
of programming style like good style
like we're back to the code smells this
isn't good programming style because all
the variables that have short letters
short names and it doesn't have comment
so you could say this is better style
where it has documentation and clear
variable names this is definitely an
aspect of programming style but as you
see it's not as strong as the styling
right thing maybe we want something like
hesitant styling programming as well
maybe I want to be able to express I
don't really know this and it's sort of
funny but it's also why not why kuda we
explore how to use style in source code
why does it have to be precise a
compiler can deal with different forms
at least with some of them there's lots
of programming language that allow you
to do one thing in different ways
so what couldn't I express has attempts
in a line of code it would be nice if I
come back to the source code ten years
later it's like oh yeah I wasn't sure
about that and maybe this would lead to
a different execution model where
instead of one variable you get a list
around a distribution around that
variable that's calculated throughout
the program our compilers could do that
so thinking about how style reflects and
writing and how that could also occur in
programming at least for me is a super
fun exercise and the same goes about
formatting to writing of course you can
say you were writing your letters and
format them in ways that extend or
enrich the meaning of your writing so
this is called a diamonds poem and here
it is shaped like a diamonds and you
have nice pictures with it it's sort of
different and it helps you understand if
you don't even know what's going on if
you just see the pictures and you see
the shape then things happen in your
brain formatting and riches what's going
on and this is something that could
exist in programming as well although
sadly not everyone agrees with me code
style essentially is a source problem
and what can honors argues in this book
is that formatting should be done should
be enforced by the language this is what
he's saying programmers should have less
freedom you shouldn't care about
formatting you need a compiler to do it
for you just fixing it when it's there
or a Bison's file where former I think
is just enforced by the language and it
only compiles if you do it the proper
way or you could
something like a linter that fixes it
for you I understand this vision but I
don't think just formatting the source
code if we're talking fashion spaces
it's covering the entire scope of what
we can do with formatting for example
here you have a piece of source code
formatted and in a way and you could say
that this program is the same program
formatted in a different way where you
put the assignments closer to the
variable that's declarations so that
it's easier to understand what variables
are used in what assignments this is not
something that a compiler could enforce
or a linter could fix because you're
making clear decisions about where you
want to use the declaration such that
they are closer to where you're going to
use them in a sense the second version
is more taking the reader true to story
like here the character here's a
character they meet
here's another character here's another
character and they meet in a book it
would rarely be the case that the first
three pages are all the actors in the
entire book and then all the stories
happen that would be super boring
so I think there's despite what Arnold
is saying there's still a lot of room to
think about how to format programs even
though we're not talking about tabs and
spaces so why is this interesting maybe
you're wondering this why what can we
learn from these ideas comparing two
things because I mean you can compare
two things there there's not always
something in I could say I am an object
and this is an object it's not
necessarily something really interesting
comparing me to I don't even know how
this thing is cool so comparing is fun
but there has to be something in it so
one of the things that is interesting in
a very detailed level is it's not only
that we can learn from writing it's also
that writing can maybe learn from
programming because we have very cool
things like syntax highlighting we do
some Auto formatting and probably write
your food :
we take a piece of source code and we
cool are the words to help us understand
what's going on and there's quite some
research actually that shows that syntax
highlighting and
helps understandability it makes you
route source code quicker this is
something we can do for writing maybe it
helps especially novice readers or
readers in a different language if you
would roll our words according to what
role they play in the sentence I'm sure
that I would be more able to read
Norwegian if the verbs would be colored
because you immediately see the
structure I know region is close enough
to Dutch so that I could also pick up
some words so this is clearly an area
where writing could learn from
programming and then of course this I do
this is a PhD dissertation right there
because how much do you feel do you mean
in the words and do you need to have
this forever or is there a learning
effect it's really interesting to do
this transformations but this is
somewhat at a very beauty level there's
a higher level of thinking that matters
here as well for example program writing
has this wonderful idea
this distinction between motors and
fencers so there are people that
identify themselves as writers Porter's
and that means you think very loud and I
have a plan I have a plotter thinking
thinking thinking the first thing you do
is think and then you just write your
story the main activity is in the
thinking up front and then you write
your story whereas if your banter I'm a
pen sir I know this the first step is
just writing you're not going to thing
you just let the story unfold itself you
start with writing and then the heavy
thinking heavy lifting happens when
you're rewriting the story and these are
two different schools and it's sort of
understood that it's not so much a
choice as it's more a thing you are and
this is very very interesting to compare
with programming because how you think
about a field really shapes what you do
in the detailed activity so compared to
puffing and panting to engineering and
you're nearing if
you're making a bridge whole thing is
the way to go you need to think about
the bridge you need to write all the
designs all the steps and all the
measurements and then you have a bridge
this works the butcher gets bends your
way out of a bridge
you can't think oh I have this idea of a
bridge I'll just build half it rich and
then I see if it's really nice and then
if it's not pretty I'll just make it
different with some food and some
concrete then it will be fine so
engineering and proofing is the same
metaphor but then we use this metaphor
in programming all the time this
architecture metaphor is everywhere
software architecture and scaffolding
and engineering maybe we're catering
more for daughters than for Panzers
where if you would see programming as
writing then so I miss metaphor for me
it really helps because sometimes I'm
closing programming if I'm making
something for a customer but sometimes
you're fencing programming you don't
really know what's going on you just
want to understand the problem by
programming programming for
understanding and this is just something
that doesn't fit the engineering
metaphor and that's interesting so
there's nothing wrong with the
engineering metaphor however it's you
should realize that the metaphor shapes
your thinking and it only represents
potentially part of a programming is
another reason why this is really
interesting and this is sort of the core
of my story is we can learn from writing
education on how to teach programming
because lots of programming education
like my stuff at the Community Center
isn't really designed they're just
fluency years and also parents that say
oh I will teach them kids programming
but they don't know education and
especially they don't know writing
education so what they do is what I did
as well let's build games and it will be
great and everyone will have fun but
there are some lessons we can learn from
writing that could very much support
programming education for example in
writing education there's this concept
called observational learning and the
way this works is a teacher explains how
they write a story while they're doing
it so they say when I create a story the
first thing I do is make a plan and then
they write the plan on the blackboard
they explain their thinking of how they
make a story and they take it's true
they're thinking and sometimes they make
a mistake and they backtrack and they
try again and in this way the idea
what's going on in their brain is
conveyed to kids in a classroom because
what's also the case if you don't use
observational learning it's teachers to
say oh let's write the story and then
it's bad but the kids don't know what
the process is so they can't really get
it and this is something that could work
in programming as well rather than
immediately have kids write the program
what you do is you create a program
while explaining or vocalizing or
thinking and then you make the program
and kids move along with you without
doing anything they're just observing
and maybe now you're thinking this is
something I do we call this live
programming and something that many
people do is in conferences rather in
conferences and in classrooms in a
presentation like this they open their
IDE and they show what they're what
they're doing go live programming so
it's something that some people have
already picked up but they don't really
make the connection between the
educational backgrounds of all the
lessons that other people have already
learned from observational learning so
like programming seems to be a really
good idea and it would be nice if this
would be employed in classrooms more and
maybe also with younger kids and I would
say again there's another PhD
dissertation in there like how long does
it need to take do we need to alternate
it with exercises in which kids write
their own source code and how often
these are all very interesting I be
asked that I will explore in the future
another thing you can learn from writing
education for programming education is
course integration so there's quite some
research
that shows that if you integrate writing
education with science education for
example that kids learn both subjects
better so imagine two control groups one
of the groups get an hour of science and
an hour of writing and related and the
other group gets two hours of integrated
lessons where for example a teacher
talks about a volcano and then the kids
have to write something about the
volcano so they do writing in the
context that matters to them and this
means they do better on both subjects
and this is something that it's very
very viable for programming as well
why couldn't we combine programming and
writing because there are so many things
that you have to explain twice otherwise
you can say hey syntax this is a
sentence in Dutch that is a real
sentence it means something here is a
line of scratch that works it does
something is the same thing and if you
change the order of these two words it
loses the meaning if you change these
two blokes it doesn't mean anything
anymore so there are concepts in
programming and writing that you could
teach together and this of course very
much relates to the donald duck lesson I
talked about earlier where kids create a
story in scratch and you could use that
as a basis for a lesson about
storytelling because afterwards you
could say what type of story was it was
it a real story or an adventure and this
is a typical exercise that eight nine
year olds who do in a classroom think
about what is a story and it doesn't
have to be a story on the paper it can
also be a story in an animation I know
we just did an experiment where we did
this for two months for two months we
thought 35 kids integrated programming
and language lessons and we measured
their own sustainability of programming
and their enjoyment of programming and
it seems in these that they are starting
to have more fun in programming and in
writing we still have to check if their
grades will also improve but that takes
some more time but the most most
interesting about this experiment that
we tried is at the end of these two
months where we keep those kids
programming and writing lessons in
we asked those kids the question what is
programming and we got the most amazing
answers some kids said it's like a
puppet theater but on the computer it's
so cool and it expresses their their
power the power they feel over the
system that they can create everything
that's going to happen you create a
story and then you share it with the
world I love this too we're changing
this idea of programming is something
you do for yourself on your computer
into I create something and everyone can
see it and this is of course not just
about our lessons but also about scratch
that the interface enables you to share
everything and this is like maybe one of
my favorite one teaching the computer to
do what you want so this this person
already is abstracting from what
programming is and then it's stories but
it's everything and it's really very
interesting if you compare these answers
to kids where we had the more game based
curriculum where we only read games so
they say programming is making games and
just less with the engineering metaphor
there's nothing wrong with programming
games but we have to be aware that if we
are projecting on kids programming is
games this is what they will think and
that that does shape our culture so I
think it's very good if we have all
these diverse type of lessons there is
no since games it's also writing it's
also science programming with
programming you can do everything that's
more or less what I wanted to share with
you
let me summarize my entire talk and
about one minute because I know it's
early and I thought really quick and
some people came in late so here's her
second shot to get the gist of this talk
if we talk about programming and
especially if we talk about teaching
program to children we have to really
think about what a is programming and
it's difficult because we are
programming all the time so we all have
our own little bubble of a programming
is but especially if you're teaching you
have to be aware that you're swimming in
water and there might be some air up
there that's also nice programming is
like writing because it's an
a level idea that you translate into
letters and sentences and you can think
what does that matter but the metaphor
we use for programming really matters
and the prevailing metaphor we have now
the engineering metaphor might not be
suitable for everyone because if you
look at writing there's this difference
between plotters and Panthers and the
engineering metaphor only fits the
floaters what I'm going to explore in my
research in the next I don't know how
long I'll still be at the University in
the next few years at least is the idea
that we can learn from writing research
to improve programming education for
example by focusing on having kids
program from the start for focusing on
showing the thinking of the teacher
before they start exercising and also
the integration of programming lessons
and language lessons because things like
syntax things like reflex reflecting and
quality things like peer review are all
things we can totally take away from
writing research that's the end i'm
celina if you want to read more about
this my blog is lena calm people always
ask me how you make this slide they're
made with good notes and an Apple pencil
Apple pencil is the best device in the
history of mankind I love it and special
thanks to smart people that helped me
design this we have some room for
questions five minutes any questions I
know it's early oh this is a good
question the 35 kids were between 8 and
10 year olds so really young and they
were still for example learning syntax
in the context of Dutch lessons this is
why we selected that age group because
we could nicely combine learning about
what is a verb and what is a noun and
learning what type of books are there
within scratch we hypothesize that would
be the best age because that you can
learn those concepts together
no more question okay let's go for
coffee then